To avoid looking at all this long tail data, we
can use the x limb parameter inside a q plot. This
parameter takes a vector where we have the start position
and the ending position of our axes. In our case, we
want to examine friend counts less than 1000. Running the
code, I can see that I have my plot with friend
counts less than 1000. Now there is another way to create
the same plot. Here I won't use the x limb parameter.
Instead I'm going to add a layer. I use limits
instead of x limb as the parameter inside of here since
I know this adjustment is already for the x axis. That's
why its called scale x continuous. There's also a counterpart for
the y axis called scale y continuous. One of the neat
concepts of GG plot is that you can build up your
plot in layers. We're going to discuss layers later in this lesson,
but for now I'm going to keep using the q plot syntax.
So far we've learned how to create histograms, how to
facet them, and how to adjust our axes. But up
until now all of our histograms have had a default
setting. We've been getting this error message for a while
about the bandwidth defaulting to a range over 30. It
turns out we can set the bandwidth ourselves to reveal
interesting trends in the data. Let's hear what happened during
Moira's investigation when she altered the bandwidth of her histogram.